[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to chess
openings explained
as always but not forever my name is
caleb denby
and tonight i want to take you through
uh some of my favorite games where white
is able to crush black
due to the use of the f pawn
specifically
moving the f pawn to f3 and you heard me
correct
not forever will i be your host because
we're doing some class programming
changes
due to my new role as assistant manager
at the chess club
so nick risco who filled in for me while
i was on vacation
is actually going to be taking the helm
for chess openings explained
moving forward and look for more changes
to come
all being updated on our website where
you can check it all out
as as we speak might take a couple days
for us to sort out the details
but in short nick risco taking over this
class so
as my final uh you know regular class
i wanted to look back and do some of the
most iconic
uh plans iconic openings that i've
talked about
and they all seem to revolve around the
move f3
and using this f pawn to take over the
center
so i wanted to talk a little bit about
what these various openings where f3 is
played
what what sort of commonalities they
have and why they can be
so powerful by showing you once again
some of my favorite games where it was
uh
used to take down black so let's start
with a
classic from 2019 so not too much of a
classic i guess
between uh indian player santosh vidit
and the one and only vladimir kramnik
with the black pieces now
this is a game starts with d4
knight f6 c4 e6
knight c3 bishop e4 and f3 so entering
my
one of my all-time favorite openings the
f3 nimzo
and now i've talked about it vaguely
before
but what i really want to touch on
tonight is why f3 can be such a powerful
move
and what sort of the the idea is so
in chess we're often told backing up to
move one you can play
e4 and take over the center with this
pawn or you can play
d4 and take over the center with this
pawn
and most most of the time what happens
is your opponent
takes control of the other other color
of squares
as you you play e4 you get these light
squares
your opponent can play e5 take the dark
squares now of course there are other
ways to play
like the french any number of openings
but basically each side gets to normally
claim
one color complex in the center even in
openings that are modern like the king's
indian defense
you'll see that black is often fighting
for control
of dark squares using uh the pawns so
openings where you don't even directly
control the center
you usually get this type of imbalance
where one side
controls the light squares in the center
and the other controls the dark squares
now
of course there are always variations on
that so what we are trying to do
with openings like the f3 nimso and
really any opening
where you play the move f3 is well
we already have some control over the
dark squares with this pawn in the
center
and we're really fighting for more here
so what white is trying to do
in this opening is take over all of the
squares in the center and that
is a very ambitious plan that is hard to
replicate
without moves like f3 and that's why i
love this opening so much it is in my
opinion one of the most ambitious ways
to fight for the center and that's why
you get really fun games
where you can sometimes just just roll
over black as we'll see here thanks to
your central majority
all right let's continue with this game
though so uh in this game kramnik plays
the move d5
which is aiming to fight back against
this plan for white right
black doesn't need to roll over and
allow white total control over the e4
square
and we've talked about this stuff before
in my f3 nimzo series
uh the move now for white is a3 forcing
black to resolve this bishop
uh or resolve the tension with this
bishop and once again
this all centers back around white's
plan of trying to get the move e4
through so in this case the bishop was
pinning the knight now black has to
decide if
this pin is worth giving up the bishop
or if black would rather retreat
and allow white to take over with e4 in
this game kramnik takes on c3
we see take back on c3 and now c5
so uh kramnik choosing one of the more
combative approaches with black here
challenging white's claim to the light
square
on e4 and also fighting
white for those dark squares as well and
the hope here for kramnik
is potentially that white will not be
able to control
both colors in the center just there's
too much to cover there
if black keeps up all this tension now
uh white's pawns are doubled so we see
white play
c takes d5 we get e takes d5 and now e3
and this is where the game takes a turn
so kramnik followed in the footsteps of
world champion
magnus carlson with the move c4 and this
is a pretty double-edged move it doesn't
have the best reputation uh
anymore even though magnus did play this
against vichyanan
uh in the world championships so that's
usually i don't know if you're aware
that's usually a match where the
the players do their opening prep but
these days c4
just doesn't have the best reputation
due to the plans that vidit was able to
uh enact
in this game here so what is the point
of c4
well c4 is one of the the few moves that
black can play
that aim at preventing white's natural
development with bishop d3
sort of the natural way of playing here
with a move like knight c6 or castles
where you just simply develop your
pieces
is actually going to lead to an
advantage for white because of the
reasons i've been talking about
white is just able to take over over
every square in the center
using this plan with bishop d3 the
bishop develops out to a natural square
and with this extra support for the e4
square
white is pretty much always able to get
the move e4 through
and really keep control over every
central square and if that happens
white has a winning advantage so in the
game though we see the move c4
by kramnik aiming to prevent bishop d3
and in a sense
forfeiting control of these dark squares
in an all-out attempt to prevent white
from achieving this move e4 so now
once again black has sort of uh
shown their hand here uh black is not
interested in fighting for the d4
square with the dark square attack with
the pawn on c5
totally committed now to controlling the
light squares
uh so that it continues out with knight
to e2
i can't develop the bishop anymore so
there's no sense in putting this bishop
in the night's way
simple development with knight e2 we see
knight c6 now
and now g4 by uh by vidig here
and this move may come as a surprise to
some of you
but it makes sense when you break down
the problems
that white is facing so number one what
does white want to do with this bishop
it's not so clear it doesn't really help
the position
on the e2 square it doesn't really do
anything that do anything extra that
it's not achieving from f1
number two if you play the move g3
you're sort of interfering with your
knight's access to g3
which is the square it would like to be
on to support the the push
through to e4 and so you arrive at this
move g4
it allows this bishop to develop out to
g2 uh supporting e4 once again
and it doesn't really block off this
knight's access to g3
in addition to that there are now some
extra ideas of even pushing this pawn
to g5 which once again would remove a
defender of the e4 square
it may seem like the plans are pretty
one note here for white but i think that
is more of a strength than a
disadvantage in an opening like this
right
uh we sort of just stack up all of our
forces against all of blacks
and say you know we're going to have
enough to play this move you're not
going to be able to stop me
and in response to this kramnik tries to
use the time
that he's bought in the center by
playing so aggressively for the light
squares
he tries to use this time on the queen's
side to to find activity over here
and find enough counter play to make
sure that he's not going to get
rolled out of the game directly now
we continue with the plan here simply
bishop g2 by vidit
we now see knight b3 by uh kramnik
and here there are actually two main
moves
that get played one is the move rook a2
and one is the move rook b1 and this is
a
pretty interesting decision that that
white has to make here
by planting the rook on b1 it serves a
very useful role
in slowing down black's queen side
counter play
but with the move rook a2 it does serve
a very useful purpose
in trying to swing back over to the
center in order to
help support the center and also keep
some pressure down the a file
as well in this case vidic chooses the
move rook b1
and i'll discuss a little bit how this
impacts the game
momentarily notably in the game between
vishyanand and magnus carlson
i think castles had castles and castles
had already been played before this
point
something like castle's castles and then
knight p3 in this position
uh vishyanan chose to play the move rook
a2 and that is a game that was
very very close out of the opening a
pretty even position and eventually
magnus went on to win due to an
unfortunate blunder by vichy at the very
end of the game
so we'll see if this rook being on b1 is
going to make a difference
in this game so rick b1 castle's castles
and now b5
and i think this is kramnik's big
mistake in the opening and it's a very
understandable mistake to make
this is actually a very treacherous
position for black against the move rook
b1 and
if you're not very well informed on what
you need to be doing
against this improvement uh quote
unquote improvement for white
with rook b1 things can get out of hand
pretty pretty quickly
so i've done quite a bit of work on this
position here uh because i think it's
really important for black
to have a move other than b5 as this
game will show
and i think the move a5 is actually
quite a bit better and you might be
wondering
what's the difference so let me turn
this question
to you chatroom what do you think the
point of this move
a5 is it may be a rather surprising one
to you guys
so yeah not talking about uh f3 on turn
one
but openings where f3 makes an
appearance because again
the one thing sort of holding these
these openings all together
is this fight for the e4 square and it's
more relevant than in an opening like
one e4
because here we're fighting for both
color complexes in the center and that
is sort of the most ambitious you can
get
and why i like these openings so much
so andrew hud says rook lift and that
is actually going to be a really really
critical
defensive idea for black in these
in these positions and it doesn't seem
like a very good defensive idea doesn't
really seem to do all that much aside
from get the rook off of this diagonal
but it's actually pretty important to
have a rook available
to support this knight on f6 even if it
doesn't seem
obvious immediately and to see why let's
take a look at what happens in the game
so we have the move b5 in the game
and here another huge improvement that
vidit finds
over vishyanan's game is to play e4
as a pawn sacrifice now it's not
sacrificing a pawn in the center
very importantly because white's plan
revolves around gaining total control
in the center but rather willingly
sacrificing
this g pawn this becomes a very very
important factor
in the game so in the game we actually
see
d takes e4 and f takes e4 and
knight takes c1 and this is another
critical difference
uh between a5 and b5 that that you can
already see
in effect so this trade of knight takes
c1 seems to be a very favorable trade
for black but with this pawn on b5 we
immediately have a weakness that is now
being targeted
by this white rook however it is a
rather difficult
position already for black to deal with
for example if something like knight
takes g4 were to be played or bishop
takes g4
you would see this bishop land on g5 and
now with the added pressure from the
rook on f1 once again this is a
situation
where having this work on a6 to be able
to help defend this knight
would be very very nice for example
let's compare this position
with this position so for example e4
take take bishop takes g4 bishop g5
and rook a6 now immediately that might
look like white has this tactical
response of playing e5 in order to win a
piece
but this actually turns out to be a
favorable position for black
due to this bishop being forced all the
way back to g3
it's not actually going to be worthwhile
for white to capture here
um number one g takes on h4
is actually playable but even stronger
than that is bringing a rook to the e
file first
when all of a sudden you see that
white's
white's problems are not so easy to
solve despite for the moment having a
peace advantage
this knight is going to be falling and
this bishop also has
some problems to solve as well so really
interesting stuff here and i wanted to
highlight this important difference
that may not seem obvious right away so
a5 much better move for black
and i think the only move that keeps
black in the game against this line
by vinit now is it all wrong for white
then at this point
not necessarily it just means that this
faster approach with e4
might not be the way to go moves like
queen c2 moves like h3
have all been tried and uh i think they
lead to very reasonable positions for
white
where white is able to still enact this
very very aggressive plan
of pushing through with e4 without
risking too much
so important note there kramnik's b5 i
do think is a really critical mistake so
e4
we see take take and then knight takes
c1 is essentially forced
because we don't have a good response to
bishop g5
now why does this matter well this
allows us to play queen take
c1 and now after bishop takes g4 we're
actually not dealing with the pin
and white is able to continue uh very
active play with the move knight to f4
and now this is the moment that
everybody dreams of
when you play an opening featuring the
move f3 we have
seen total domination in the center
every single central square
is under white's control and the these
are quite honestly my favorite positions
in all of chess to play
you just control every single central
square and your opponent is sort of left
left quite helpless uh as a result of
this
kramnik continues the game though with
rook to b8 this is really the only move
that solves the immediate tactical
issues uh for black
now h3 is wit its response just forcing
this bishop away from its active square
kramnik chooses bishop d7 which does
have the unfortunate side effect
of interfering with this queen's access
to the center even further and then it
doesn't take a genius to find that its
next move
simply e5 taking over more and more
squares as we push through the center
now what used to be a pretty
double-edged situation in the center uh
as few as five moves ago
where white had the dark squares black
had the light squares
now we see white has taken over these
light squares and with e5
is now even uh encroaching upon black's
dark squares
firmly in kramnik's own camp here f6 and
d6
both now squares that are available to
white
uh black pushes or black retreats with
knight d ea8
and now we see vidit simply activating
the queen with queen to e3
uh rook b6 played in the game and now d5
and this is why this is one of my
favorite games
in the f3 nimzo uh it takes this idea of
using
f3 to push through with e4 and sort of
puts it to the extreme where you just
see these central pawns
rolling down the center black now unable
to control
all four of these squares on the sixth
rank a really
really tough situation to be in if
you're pl if you're vladimir kramnik
now kramnik does try this move knight c7
and white
just continues the the punishment here
with the move d6 so now
what was once a double-edged situation
in the center white now controls d4
e4 d5 e5 d6
f6 and e7 and c7
now black has regained control over the
e6 square
in reply to this but it's sort of too
little too late we see this light square
coming back under white or black's
control but now knight d5
and and the rest is sort of history here
we see rook a6
now rook f5 and the fifth rank is almost
entirely
under uh under bit its control queen h4
was probably the final blunder of the
game for kramnik
apparently king h8 is a better try to
stay in the game
stepping out of unfortunate checks and
tactics of that manner
but quite honestly this is a a lost
position for
kramnik already it's sort of beyond
saving queen h4 played in the game
though
and now we see uh vidit simply doubling
up here ready to play 97
and snap on the f7 square
rook takes a three played in the game
for kramnik going
for this sort of natural queen side
counter play
but obviously it's it's too little too
late this this one rook excursion over
here on the queen side is not
uh not dissuading that it from the the
natural plant we see 97 check
king h8 rook f7 rook f7 rook f7
and now queen h5 and one more important
move to find here
white to move and win everybody see if
you can find the final move of the game
final move of the game here what do you
think that it played
what did it play nobody knows nobody
knows this time
so not queen f3 and importantly not
queen f2
but actually the meanest queen to f4
was vida's choice highlighting the fact
that this queen is uncapturable
due to the threat of checkmate and now
rook f8 is simply an unstoppable threat
if you try to go h6 this isn't going to
be good enough
rook f8 takes takes
and mate or if you like uh
king h7 and bishop b4 check now why not
queen f3 or queen f2 well queen f3 would
actually allow
a trait of queens when all of a sudden
white might actually be in trouble
with all of these pawns sort of coming
down
this way and queen f2 actually allows a
little bit of a trick
by black rook a1 check is playable and
this hasn't spoiled the entire game but
after bishop to
f1 notably you are missing this bishop
e4
check in the line uh involving h6 so
after rookie fight
king h7 for the moment black is actually
still in the game
so kind of a clever trick there by
kramnik to try to stay back in the game
but vidit navigates it successfully with
the move uh queen to f4
now okay i guess i should explain what
the difference is why not king h2 well
of course e5 is hanging
and this is not allowed by queen f4 now
against or k1
we do simply play king h2 and there's no
queen e5 check
so really great game by vidic here and i
think this really
once again pushes the idea of f3 to the
extreme
uh at its core f3 is an ambitious
ambitious move in any opening it's
played in
to try and take over all of the central
squares
uh and that's why i love it so much so
questions on on this opening
in this game in particular before we
move along to another example here
all right well let us move along then so
from the f3 nimzo i now want to take you
guys to
uh one chess player who you might have
heard of by the name
of gary kasparov and
this chess player in particular was sort
of known for many things
but one thing he was quite quite good at
was
breaking down the queen's gambit
declined and so i'm going to take a look
at how kasparov
actually uses this move f3 against the
qgd
to come up with effective plans and once
again we'll see
just take over the entire center that is
the uniting theme
of these f3 openings that i really
really enjoy they just try to take over
absolutely everything and when it works
well it really
really works well so let's take a look
here this is actually from
depending on who you ask i think this is
from a world championship
back when uh kasparov was having this
fight with fidei over who
who had the real world championship
against nigel short back in 1993
so two pretty good chess players we have
d4 d5
c4 e6 knight c3 and knight f6
so we get to a queen's game but decline
a pretty normal position
notably though white has played a move
order that leaves this knight back
on g1 and develops the night out to c3
first now you'll see oftentimes this
move order played
and players with the white pieces will
often times simply play knight f3
because they don't like the nemzo indian
now because we've seen vidit's game
we're not afraid of the nimzo indian
because you know it's that simple
but this is why uh
you can get this position with uh with
white and
players with the black pieces honestly
aren't always happy
about this move order by white they
would much rather see the knight come
out to f3
first and the main reason for that is it
allows white to play the line that gary
that gary employs here we see c takes d5
e takes d5
entering the qgd exchange
from here white continues out with
bishop g5 normal queen's game but
decline moves
e3 getting ready to develop castles
bishop d3 no need to delay developing
this bishop because we've resolved the
tension between the pawns on d5 and c4
knight bd7 by nigel short and now knight
g to e2 and this is the critical
difference between your quote unquote
normal
uh queen's gambit declined variations
and the move order
gary has played here we don't put this
knight on f3
we actually put it on e2 with the idea
of putting our pawn
on f3 the game continues now with rook
to e8s
sort of anticipating this type of plan
we get king side castles
now knight f8 by nigel short
and here gary kasparov sort of does a
mixing of the plans now usually this is
a term
uh meant to mean you've done something
wrong but here it just means
gary is combining the ideas of the
minority attack on the queen's slide
with these f3 ideas of playing in the
center and the result is going to be a
very very uncomfortable position
for nigel to have to deal with we see b4
by gary kasparov also taking advantage
of a bit of a tactic
where if bishop takes b forward to be
played bishop takes f6 is going to lead
to a pretty big advantage
for white if the queen were to take then
the d pawn falls
and g takes f6 is not ideal for obvious
reasons
and perhaps less obviously the move
knight takes d5
is going to be available to white here
as well if queen takes
d5 or to be played queen a4 surprise
surprise
attacks two pieces that are both
undefended and there's no good way
for black to recap or black to defend
both queen a4
simple fork so b4 clever tactic by gary
in the opening here
that being said this is not like a
unique thing that nigel missed this is
still
a sort of well-established theory
a6 played by nigel short instead
aiming to control the b5 square and not
allow this pawn to get too out of
control
and now we do see gary simply defending
this pawn on b4 so some opening trickery
there
but we're going to end up in a fairly
normal position anyways
c6 by nigel shoring up the pawn
structure
and fighting against the idea of b5
now queen c2 by gary uh just another
improving move before we see the pawn
come out to f3
uh i should say f3 is also perfectly
playable here and gary himself has
actually also played this exact position
so nothing too crazy just queen c2 we
see g6
by nigel short defending against
some of this pressure on the light
squares over here and also perhaps
anticipating
an eventual idea of bringing something
to f5 be it a bishop
be it perhaps even uh a pawn uh via some
maneuvers
like like this uh now in the game we
finally see
gary play this move f3 so i want to
pause
for a moment here and ask you guys to
get your impression of this position
compared to the last one that we just
saw obviously many many things are
different
right black still has a dark squared
bishop for example uh
and white's immediate plan of e4 seems
to be coming a bit more slowly
in this case so what do you guys think
of this position is this
going to work out for gary or not
who's jerry this is a good idea i mean a
good question not a good idea
i don't know i don't know what the chat
room is talking about anymore
ben's ben feingold says never play f3
this is my anti-ben feingold episode
alright i've done a lot of episodes on
playing f3 before
but if one was to be specifically
uh anti-benefiting gold i guess this is
the one all right i'm
advocating heavily for this move f2 f3
advocating heavily
uh and so you you guys have a lot of
good ideas here the the point i want to
really highlight
is that despite all of the differences
despite you know black c pawn being on
c6 rather than c4 despite the inclusion
of this bishop in this knight
compared to the previous position
despite the pawn not being on g4
despite this bishop being on a different
square on d3 rather than g2
white's plan is going to remain the same
and that just
speaks to the actual power of this game
plan here like i said
it's sort of the most ambitious plan you
can really go for in an opening
controlling all four central squares
it's not something
that is very easily accomplished which
is why we have to play a quote-unquote
weakening move like f3 in order to go
for it
so despite all the differences in the
structure white's plan is going to
remain the same here
and that is something uh really
incredible
that i don't think you see in many
openings here this sort of robust
plan uh being effective against a
variety
of structures not to call it like a
system or anything because it's pretty
far from the system
but this idea of f3 sort of persists
so in the game uh nigel short continues
with knight e6
forcing this bishop to make a decision
gary simply retreats no reason to uh to
give it up for this knight
and now we see knight h5 by uh
by nigel so bishop takes e7 played in
the game
i think bishop f2 might have been a very
reasonable move
as well but we'll see that gary has
another piece in mind for the f2 square
so we get bishop takes e7 and not queen
takes but rook takes on e7
now queen d2 is going to be gary's move
here
just ensuring there's no funny tactics
against the undefended e3 pawn for the
moment
and now we see b6 by nigel
now sort of the the problem of the
position is making itself apparent
right uh compared to the previous game
black had a very active idea of
expanding on the queen side
and in this game gary has sort of nipped
that in the bud
by this early a3b4 advance with these
pawns here controlling the dark squares
on the queen side
gary wasn't necessarily always intending
the minority attack although that option
was certainly open
but now they serve more of a restricting
role
making sure and that black isn't able to
get the kind of activity
that we saw in kramnik's game so
white has a very clear plan we want to
push e4 in the center and
organize our pieces to support that
meanwhile
black doesn't really have much to do on
the queen side thanks to these pawns by
gary
and doesn't really have much much of an
attack to speak of on the king's side
either and for those reasons i do think
that practically
white has a much much better position
because of the clarity of the plan and
that is something you get
in these f3 openings that isn't always
so easy to find
so gary continues with rook 8's d1
simply supporting the d4 pawn
in preparation of the push to e4 now we
see bishop b7
by nigel short and bishop b1 by gary
kasparov and
all of a sudden what is black to do how
are you supposed to actually stop this
pawn from arriving
on e4 i'm not so sure that there is
a viable way to do this if you go all
out crazy
something like f5 you might run into g4
but
simply e4 anyways is also going to be
very powerful
if we take everything off the board
guess who still controls all the central
squares
it's it's white and so after bishop b1
i would say in a practical sense nigel
short is
as close to losing the game here uh
knight hg7
is what was played in the game again
sort of doing these weird maneuvers
around the f5 square but they were all a
little bit too slow to slow down white's
plan
of of e4 here gary simply pushes
and the rest is is sort of history as
we've seen
before once gary plays this move
all of the central squares are now in
play for white
and black is is very much falling behind
trying to keep control of them
the difference here is that with this
pawn on c6
black still does for the moment have a
fighting chance at controlling the d5
square
so moves like d takes e4 which were sort
of forced in kramnik's game
are now definitely uh not going to be
the best idea
for nigel short if we were to see d
takes e4 and f takes e4
i think many people would agree we have
this ideal situation
that you sort of dream of in the f3
openings where we control every square
in the center
and that is not something black is
interested in allowing
so instead we see black keep this
tension here with the move rook c8
and i included this game uh well number
one because gary kasparov plays very
very well in it
and number two because i wanted to take
a look at this sort of situation right
we've achieved our big plan we pushed
through with e4 we're fighting for all
of the scores in the center
but our opponent hasn't really rolled
over and died just yet so how how do we
continue now how do we continue
now that we've achieved e4 and you know
the game isn't over
what to do here with white
this gary guy is strong i agree
so amir says push e5
that's an interesting interesting idea
e5 for g4 push
any other plants that the chatroom can
see
all right i'm getting some individual
moves but but no
uh no direct plans so there's a few
ideas that i
don't like so we've won the fight
for the for the e4 square everybody can
kind of agree right we've won this fight
we got e4
we were able to push it through now the
question is what do we do
with our e4 pawn we got it there we did
it what do we do next
so one plan which is very very
reasonable and perhaps is
objectively correct in many many cases
is to play e5
now i like this plan in many many cases
and i don't like it
in other cases so in this case i think
e5 is a very very
reasonable move i don't think it's a bad
move at all and uh
it's definitely something that gary
could have gone for in my opinion
and the idea here is to use your e4 pawn
now an e5 pawn as the launching point
for an attack on the king's side
so with e5 you get this nice attack on
the king side thanks to this pawns
good control over these squares however
there is a downside to playing the move
e5
in our heart of hearts we played f3 in
hopes to take over the entirety of the
center
and after we play the move e5 we sort of
admit that that was a little bit too
ambitious and we're not
actually going to achieve it we're
giving up on the d5
square and kind of the e4 square if
we're continuing through with
with f4 we can claim that the e4 square
is going to be useless to black because
we control all the squares around it
but we are at least giving up on the d5
square
so is this plan a good plan in many many
cases yes
in some cases it's the only plan in this
case i think it's a fine plan
but what gary did is perhaps meaner and
that should really be our goal
in chess aside from winning we just want
to be really mean
to our opponents and make them uh you
know
quit and go into uh chess administration
rather than chess playing which gary was
successful in
in this case although it had sort of a
delayed effect
and gary does this with bishop a2 so
what we see gary going for rather than
the plan of closing the center with e5
taking extra space on the king's side
and launching an attack
instead we see gary saying no uh you
can't have the d5 square either
i'm taking over the entire center so in
a sense
kind of sticking with the original plan
here just trying to take over
absolutely every square in the center
not allowing nigel short any active
counter play
whereas against the move e5 perhaps
black has
a hint a smidgen of counter play
fighting back
for once again the center we played e5
perhaps giving up some of our central
control
and black is ready to pounce with the
idea of c5
now against bishop a2 c5 is obviously
going to be a losing move
because we haven't given up our fight
for the d5 square just yet
and this is really going to keep black a
little bit more at bay
rook d7 is how nigel short decided to
continue
trying to support this pawn in the
center and now we see knight af knight
f4
by gary really just ratcheting up the
pressure
against d5 uh nigel short was quick
to trade on f4 and bring the second
knight in to e6
but now gary was able to improve the
queen out to e5
and once again just continuing to
ratchet up the pressure
against the e5 pawn rookie 7 is how
nigel short opted to continue and now we
see a little bit of dancing with gary
retreating the queen back to g3
and queen c7 by nigel short
and now queen h4 by gary so a little bit
of
roaming around with the queen but what
we have actually seen
is with this uh sort of shuffling the d5
pawn has been even further weakened by
this
uh replacing of black's pieces right
knight g7 is how
natural short opted to continue and
honestly this move is
a little bit confusing uh to me i i
don't fully understand
what the point of knight g7 was i guess
to
allow this rook to to sort of see along
the e file
but i i don't think this is really going
to be a path to success here
for for nigel we see the move rook c1
now
by kasparov and this looks as if it's
moving pieces away from the center
but really it's just allowing this rook
the d1 square
to enter the fray along with increasing
pressure down the c file
which in a sense is still helping
control the d5 square
queen d8 by nigel rick fd1 by gary
and now rook c to c7 by nigel short
and finally here we see the move knight
a4 by
gary kasparov and at this point
uh nigel sort of uh throws in the towel
in the fight for the d5 square
and in the fight for the center so the
question is
why does nigel decide this is the time
to uh to give up the fight here well
if you do see a move like rook c to d7
a number of things could happen here
number one it's not too late to go for
this e5 plan
and in this case it may be even stronger
than when we first looked at it now
why is that well because we still have
pressure over here on the queen side
and black has sort of placed all of the
pieces
in the center ready to prepare for an
opening of the center
and has lost control over this c5 break
so we get all the benefits of e5
with sort of none of the counter play
thanks to the stroke on c1
and this knight on a4 now white's just
going to continue f4 g4
f5 and the classic attacking plan that
we were discussing earlier
now aside from that it's not entirely
out of the question
that uh gary would just continue to be
very very mean to his opponent
just play something like king h1 and
continue sitting on the position
waiting for black to finally crack and
try to take on e4
now notably of course the move rook
takes d4 is not going to be working here
because that queen is a little bit
overworked
uh but basically what gary does
is he ratcheted up the pressure against
d5 continued playing with the pawns
sitting on d4 and e4 not willing to ever
really give
up on the fight for all of the central
squares and eventually
black ran out of active things to do and
decided now is the time
to take on e4 so we get f takes c4 and
now
a slightly strange looking move of queen
to e8 so sacrificing the b6 pawn
uh for an attack against the e4 pawn now
unfortunately for nigel i do think this
was still the wrong decision i think it
was better to play something like roxy
to d7 and keep the tension for as long
as possible
because now this bishop is open and once
again all four central squares
are firmly in white's control knight
back to c3 is gary's simple reply
and there's simply nothing black can do
to maneuver around
the entirety of the center rook c to d7
is the continuation now and queen back
to f2
is the nice supporting square for the
queen
utilizing the open f file supporting the
center and even
perhaps attacking the b6 pawn uh with a
d5 discovery
knight e6 is how nigel decided to
continue now we do see the move e5
now the d5 square has been given up on
we can see gary
utilizing the remainder of the central
squares that he
uh won in the hard-fought battle like
the move knight e4 a move that would not
be possible if the pawn
was still on d5 c5 is
nigel's continuation to try to fight for
this square uh
but at this point it's too little too
late we see takes takes and now d5
in a very similar situation to what we
saw in vidit's game
just total domination in the center of
the board and gary kasparov
is just winning this game quite easily
knight d4 by nigel and the simple
response
knight e4 we see that all of the central
squares are in white's control uh
you might claim that the d4 square is in
black's control but i would argue that
this is a very temporary thing
because you know this pawn is hanging
and knight f6 check is coming
and white gave up sort of control of the
d4 square to gain con
to gain just a winning winning position
by force
uh queen d8 now by nigel short knight f6
check
is of course just winning in exchange
directly
now rook takes c5 and it's quite clear
that once again all of the squares are
are coming under white's white's control
here
sorry rook takes d7 was played not queen
takes but still rook takes c5 is played
knight e6 was played and now rook c to
c1 and
that is the match here uh nigel short
resigns and garrick sparrow
wins you might be thinking isn't the d5
pawn hanging and
you would be correct but also incorrect
because queen f6 check
is going to be a winner of a tactic uh
successfully removing this queen from
the defense of d5 if you take here
i take with check and win a bishop and
if you don't take
i take the queen and now i take the
bishop still
so rooksy to c1 the final move of this
game and once again
sort of a picturesque position where
white has just completely taken over the
center
and with it the entire game all right so
let's uh turn it over to the chat again
uh does anybody have any questions on
how gary won this game
and the plan he he chose to go for a lot
of you came up with this e5 f4 plan
uh with the king side attack the sort of
more normal plan that we've seen
but i did want to highlight this game
just to show that there is sort of
another way
where you just continue fighting for
every single central square
and with it you know just dominating the
game
noodle soup says there are multiple
moves where short could have played d
takes e4
followed by rooker knight takes d4 i'm
not so sure that's true
maybe there were times when it appeared
to be that way but
uh i don't think at least tactically it
ever would have been working i can
scroll through quickly let's see if i
can find where you're talking about
and similarly keldrick i don't think
there was ever a moment where with all
the tension on d5
kasparov could have just outright won a
pawn here right he plays knight f4 to
try to attack it even further
but black immediately removes this
attacker and goes goes for this
and after rookie 7 it once again it
might appear that there's some e takes
d5 tactic
but i'm not so sure it's really working
with this kind of uh
kind of tension here and actually i i
guess rick d7 would be the response
uh with you know the tactics just barely
working out for black
uh okay uh but yeah as far as taking on
d4
and or taking on e4 and taking here uh
again the tactics just simply aren't
quite working out right we have these
inner mesos to remove these attackers
and then we are still controlling the
center
so a little bit of tactics behind the
scenes there to keep everything together
how do we know when to advance the
center is it all calculation is it a
sixth
sense uh so that this is a good question
so if you're talking about this exact
moment uh here
where cass kasparov plays bishop a2 um
you could call the sixth sense
or you could call it just positional
understanding uh bishop a2
is you know a perfectly fine move to
keep the the
the sort of tension in the position e5
is also a perfectly fine move
it sort of comes down to your preference
here now how do you know when to play a
move like e5
well you should always be aware of your
opponent's counterplay this is the
reason i think why kasparov chose not to
play e5 here
if he had chosen to play e5 black
suddenly has an active idea with the
with the move pawn to c5 i'm not saying
this is great for black i'm not saying
white has blown
the advantage or anything because the
pawn on e5 is still quite strong
but black at least has an active plan
you can compare this with bishop a2
where as you saw in the game nigel was
sort of struggling
to find the same active plan that would
come
quite readily with the move c5 in the
other case
if you mean pushing the pawn to e4 in
this particular opening i don't think
there's any rush at all
you can sort of play it at multiple
moments here you can also just
continue sitting on the position by the
way like playing a move like king h1
i don't think is really going to spoil
the position here uh
with with e4 to follow you can sort of
take your time in many cases
uh here though kasparov just decided
that the moment was right there's no
reason to delay any further
and later he advances why was that the
right moment okay so when kasparov does
push to e5
notably it's after short opens the
position
with d takes e4 and so the reason why we
see e5 here
is because he has the immediate idea of
occupying the e4 square
and with it winning the game so don't
take this move lightly
uh e4 to e5 you can do it if you
immediately have like this
this kind of follow up with with some
piece landing on e4 and coming into the
game
and you can do it if you're not actually
giving up any squares
so look at the squares the pawn controls
and after e5
if it's going to be relevant that the
pawn is no longer controlling those
squares
then you should think very hard about
this move in this case it's not relevant
because black is essentially forced to
try to stop this move
and with the move attempting to stop it
we see that's
you know it doesn't matter that this
pawn no longer controls d5
because we're gaining that square with
our pieces anyways so
the pawns are sort of ideally placed i
would say on d4 and e4
and pushing them any further than that
you want to be sure you're
number one able to control the squares
that the pawn was
uh controlling before it advanced or
number two you just have
a path into the game to sort of
immediately just kind of wreck the
position
as knight e4 does here like knight e4 is
just sort of a game ender at this point
and you can find that by calculating but
like optically it just looks like a game
ender right like there's no coming back
if this knight lands on f6 or d6
okay with all of that stuff let us move
along
to game number three so for game number
three i actually want to
stick with the queen's gambit declined
and furthermore i want to stick with one
gary kasparov because once again uh
gary sort of loved beating people in
this f3 qgd
it's sort of what he did for a living
for a while there and he did it against
many many many of his opponents so once
again
let's check out how gary uh achieved
this sort of plan
this time against a grand master by the
name of bozodar
ivanovic uh back in 1983.
so taking a look here we have once again
d4 and out of 6 c4
e6 and this is again that move order i
mentioned
uh gary not fearing the nemzo chose the
move knight to c3
and instead of the nimzo black chose
pawn to d5 in this case oh actually no
i'm sorry
this one is also nimzo indian wait a
second okay i got my games mixed up
i was gonna show another game the qgd
but instead we're going back to the f3
nimzo
i apologize so bishop b4 and here
we see e3 so the chat room
is so confused i said it's all about f3
tonight yet
gary here plays the move pawn to e3
and the uh thing i'm going to point out
here
is that there are a couple different
move orders in a couple different
ways you can arrive at a position where
f3 is a very reasonable move
and here we're going to see despite
starting with an e3 nimzo indian
or the rubenstein depending on who you
ask gary still is able to navigate
the game towards the type of position we
were talking about
where he's going to try to take over all
four central squares
so let's see that in action uh black
chooses the move c5
fighting for the dark squares and after
this move
gary chooses the immediate a3 once again
forcing this bishop
to relieve the tension here and in this
case black captures
and we see white capture so the f3 nimzo
indian
it's a lot like this f3 qgd that we saw
but with this extra sort of support on
d4
uh playing the pawn out to e4 may be
even easier
than uh than in the previous cases all
right we see
castles by black bishop d3 by
gary now d5 by ivanovic
c takes d5 e takes d5 and now knight e2
and this should be a sort of telltale
stein sign
as to what gary has in mind here once
again he wants to push the pawn to f3
and play for the e4 square we get b6 by
ivanovic
and f3 alright rookie 8 by ivanovic
kingside castles and now bishop a6 and
we have now
a textbook f3 nemzo indian position uh
by transposition of course because gary
started with e3 but this is actually the
exact position you can get
by playing uh f3 on move four directly
and rather than the the game that we saw
where
uh kramnik was playing with the black
pieces and went for an immediate c4
here we see that the bishop was able to
stay on d3 able to develop out naturally
and instead black keeps this pawn on c5
and this is just
one more way black can try and play
to prevent the pawn push through to e4
so we're gonna see
how this plan works out for black here
against gary
in the game gary simply plays knight g3
ready to support the e4 square even
further
and black snaps off on d3 in an effort
to develop this night out right can't
keep the tension
uh and also develop out the night
and now i want to ask the chat room what
you think
gary kasparov's next move was because
this is a pretty
instructive one in my opinion so white
to move here
what do you think gary plays
noodle soup is referencing one of my
favorite games of chess
of course he's talking about buttfnet
cappa blanca
in avro 1938 i believe
uh there's a running joke between uh
jonathan trans and i who you may know
about how grandmasters are always able
to cite uh
site games that uh or historical chess
games that the positions remind them of
and so jonathan and i no matter the
position always reference it back
to botfin at kappalanka avro 1938
regardless of what's on the board in
this case though it makes sense
okay lots of ideas in the chat rook a2
has been suggested with the idea of
lifting the rook
up and over the machuca rook so to speak
to support the pushes in the center rook
e1 is also a very common
response the immediate e4 has been
suggested as well
and lastly the idea i want to talk about
is bishop to e2
so believe it or not the immediate e4 is
not without merit here
due to some immediate tactics against
this knight on f6
like we saw in the vidic game but the
slower approach i think is also
perfectly fine here without getting
into these messy complications like once
again
chess is a game uh with with plenty of
tactics to worry about
and so a move like e4 sort of abandons
any of these positional goals of taking
over the entire center
and instead just steers the game towards
immediate tactics with an opening of the
position
whereas the move gary plays bishop b2 i
think
is very very correct and very good in
this case
so why bishop b2 this move looks sort of
obscene
right you're putting this bishop behind
not one but two pawns on this diagonal a
diagonal that looks like it has very
little hope of ever opening
but this idea simply goes back to our
goal in the opening we want to push
through e4
and fight for literally every central
square
and now if we were to do this
immediately no matter how the tactics
work out
it would be upon sacrifice here now i
said this might be playable because
bishop g5 could be strong
but regardless of that this is upon
sacrifice so with bishop b2
white is showing how committed he is to
this plan of playing e4
by quite uh concretely just adding
another defender
to the d4 pawn now as far as the rook
a2 idea this is still a great idea in
many f3 nimzo indians
the reason why it's not so correct here
is because
uh compared to other versions of this
opening where we have the queen on d1
and the bishop on d3
the queen has already been lifted to d3
and because of this
the rook has easy access to the center
after our move of bishop b2
so you're correct to be worried about
bringing this rook into the center
but your method is just not quite
correct here because the first rank has
been entirely cleared
it just makes a little bit more sense to
use this bishop effectively
and also clear a path for the rook into
the game
now as far as rook to e1 i'm going to
claim that this is probably the worst of
the natural
moves quote unquote because it doesn't
really recognize what the problem is
for white in the position if you count
the defenders and attackers on e4
we have three sort of attackers i guess
by black
and one two three defenders so if white
wanted to play e4
you could right now black can't win this
pawn the issue is
the pawn on d4 which is why bishop b2 is
much more correct than rook to e1
we don't need more support for this move
just yet we need more support
for the pawn on d4 so that we can play
this move
if that makes sense now that being said
bishop b2
does look like a bit of a screamer after
you see the move c4
so similar to the kramnik game now we
see uh
ivanovic playing c4 under slightly
different circumstances here
uh in this case it's not necessarily
about uh
keeping a piece off of d3 it's about
keeping this bishop from participating
in the game
on this b2 diagonal our a1h8 diagonal
there's still some pressure on the d2
pawn so rather than the natural move
queen c2
queen d2 or e2 must be played
in this case queen d2 by kasparov now we
see queen d7
by ivanovic and simply rook a to e1
by uh by gary and you might be thinking
i'm stretching
the the limits of like what is getting
crushed in the opening
you know with f3 because we're already
on move 16
but the fact of the matter is this
really is still
sort of an opening here and i think gary
essentially has a winning position
it's not clear that gary's position is
winning just yet
but then you have to ask yourself what
does black do
like what does black do here white is
playing e4
on the very next move this was the price
of playing c4 you gave up
your fight for the d4 pawn and now
you're going to get crushed
once white is able to achieve e4 thanks
to the total dominance in the center as
we've been talking about
uh and for those reasons i i think
i think black is just totally busted
here once again against the power
of f3 all right h5 played in the game
now we get the pawn moving out to e4 no
sense in delaying
even the idea of h4 temporarily
displacing this knight is not going to
be good enough here because
the second you try to take on uh e4
for any reason you're going to be met
with some hard
realities after this queen lands on g5
uh yeah i think queen g5 here is is
quite strong
there's simply no good way to respond to
this rip g4
is meant by the nasty nasty nasty knight
h6 check
and g6 of course is gonna mean um
queen takes f6 for one i think
threatening mate
and yeah stuff like this just gets quite
awkward right it gets quite awkward
i think black is simply getting getting
checkmated
in this case okay
so h4 not good enough which is why this
idea of h5 was perhaps a little bit
flawed to begin with
instead ivanovich tries g6 and we simply
reroute the bishop back to c1 so we're
not too proud
to admit that our bishop looks bad on b2
once black has played the move c4 it
served its purpose there and now comes
back into the game
knight h7 is played and rather than play
e5
f4 f5 why give up the fight for this
square so soon
simply well first queen h6 and then f4
we don't really need to play e5 in this
case uh we are still going
for the plan of attacking on the king
side as evidenced by queen to h6
but we're still fighting for the entire
center
97 played by ivanovic now simply f5
and there's there's no place left to
hide if you're if you're black here
g takes h5 queen takes h or g takes f5
queen takes h5
d takes e4 knight takes f5 and the
center does get blown up
but once again in this case there's
simply no reply
to to white's attack on the king's side
and ivanovic
actually goes ahead and resigns in this
position
uh so once again uh with my final chess
openings explained lecture
at least for the near future i wanted to
go back through
what is essentially my favorite opening
plan in chess
using this f3 pawn to try to take over
the entire center i feel like if there's
been one running theme
through all of my openings lectures it's
it's been this
one idea it leads to really really fun
games
and it's it's one of my favorite things
to do in chess it feels really really
good
when you pull it off successfully and
your opponent is just left with
with absolutely nothing to do so
hopefully you guys
found this lecture instructive once
again though i might not be teaching it
anymore but we still are
going to keep chess openings explained
going it's going to be
some good quality content by nick risco
who you've seen on the channel before
now
so definitely come back next week same
exact time to see
how nick is going to take the reins here
uh with all that in mind if you're
watching live
please do head on over to twitch for
tactics time
uh if you've had enough chests for
tonight or if you're watching the video
replay
uh as always and for the last time in
chess openings explained i want to thank
you guys
very very much for watching my name is
caleb denby
and i will not see you next time
you